i've done a bunch of videos now on
inflation and deflation how they can be
impacted by capacity utilization
and the traditional notion of
capacitization and this is kind of what
my brain does when someone mentions it
is i think of industrial capacitization
i imagine factories and when people say
low utilization i imagine idle factories
and when high utilization i imagine
factories that are running at three
shifts and uh you know things are moving
feverishly but in a service based
economy like like we have here in the us
and like we have in a lot of western
societies most of our real capacity for
what we produce or our gdp
is service based because we're a
service-based economy and if you think
about it industrial
industrial capacitization it matters but
it matters much more in a manufacturing
based economy in a service-based economy
the best measure of utilization really
is uh unemployment and i guess we could
say the best measure of of under
utilization is unemployment with that
with that said i think it's it's really
important to kind of have a deeper
understanding of how unemployment is
measured and how it's thought about from
the government and what you know the
numbers you hear on on cnn what they
really mean in terms of the real
unemployment picture and most of these
charts actually all of these charts that
i have in this video i got from mike
shedlock who runs the global economic
analysis blog and i had a conversation
with him in friday and he pointed out
some some really interesting things and
that's what i really want to cover and i
think it'll give us a a good general
view of an unemployment and give us some
clues as to what's going on right now
but i encourage you to read his blog he
goes by mish
and he tells people that the best way to
find his blog is just do a search on
google for mish and he does a lot of
this where he kind of looks at the
economic data but he goes several levels
deeper than anyone really would go
especially on tv but that's what you
really have to do to really discern what
matters with that said and once i want
to give him full credit because he
really is the who pointed out a lot of
this to me but i think it's very
instructive to the capacity utilization
and inflation deflation argument that
i've been making
so right here i have a screenshot from
the bureau of labor statistics and you
could go there just you know do a search
for them
and what most people really don't
realize is just like on the money supply
you have different measures of money
supply you also have different measures
of unemployment and the number that you
hear reported at least since 1994 is u3
and that's where we'll start
that's kind of the official rate of
unemployment i know you can't read this
properly my screen capture software
doesn't do well with this font but you
three total unemployed as a percent of
the civilian labor force so it's very
important to realize what they consider
unemployed and what they consider the
the labor voice labor force they
consider you unemployed if you don't
have a job and
you have looked for work
looked for work
in the past four weeks
past four weeks and this is a really
important point it really is important
to think about it relative to everything
else i'll go over in this video because
we all know and we've probably had times
in our life where
we considered ourselves unemployed or we
considered someone else unemployed but
they had maybe gotten dejected and
stopped looking a little bit or decided
to take a break and it's important to
realize that the numbers that we hear
from the government they don't count as
part of the civilian labor force if you
you know if you'd look for job for
four weeks
well let's say you stopped looking for a
job for five weeks you wanted to take a
break and maybe you know redo your
resume for a while so you're kind of
passively looking for a job the
government no longer considers you part
of the labor force and you're not
included in that number
they do have broader numbers that do
include that and i think that's
important uh because we're actually
going to study the difference between
the different numbers
u4 is total unemployed so it's a number
up here plus discouraged workers
as a percent of the civilian labor force
plus
discouraged workers right so they're
going to add the discouraged workers to
the numerator
right they're gonna so before you had
unemployed
over
let me do this in a different color
before you had this is the standard one
you have unemployed over employed plus
unemployed as defined and where they say
unemployed is someone who doesn't have a
job but you've looked for a job in the
last four weeks u4 is now
let me do it in a different color it is
i have to do it
it is unemployed plus discouraged over
employed plus unemployed plus
discouraged workers and their definition
of discouraged workers we had i just
talked about people who haven't looked
or actively looked for a job in more
than five weeks or actually more than
four weeks you're considered discouraged
if you give a reason
for that and you say well i'm i just
haven't looked for it because i'm
discouraged because i don't think there
are
jobs for what i want to do anymore so
that's the reason why i haven't looked
for it and that's when you you get
included into this bucket and then u5 is
that same thing but what they do is they
add
other marginally attached workers and
the difference between a discouraged
worker and a marginally attached worker
a discouraged worker gives the economic
reason they say i haven't looked for a
job in the past five weeks because i
just think it's impossible i want to
work but it's just it's just impossible
to find a job as an accountant or an
engineer anymore while a marginally
attached worker
also says i haven't looked for a job in
the last five weeks but they don't say
it's because they think the economy is
making it impossible it could just be
they you know they're i don't know
depressed generally they don't want to
um i mean it could be a whole set of
reasons it's it's the important thing is
it's on the survey that that the bureau
the
bureau of labor statistics conducts that
they don't literally give that uh that
that argument that the only reason that
they're not looking for is economic
reasons and then they'll they'll be put
into the marginally attached workers and
that's u5 and then u6 and u6 is really
interesting because it includes all of
these above but actually shifts some
people right so this u5 you would add
marginally attached to the numerator and
denominator there
u6 what you do is you have total
unemployed plus all marginally attached
workers plus total employed part-time
for economic reasons as a percent of the
civilian labor force plus all largely
attached workers so the important thing
here is
plus total employed part-time for
economic reasons
that's key so the denominator doesn't
change anymore but this
unemployed number is going to get bigger
because there's some part of the
employed population who they're not
working 40 hours a week or they're not
working as much as they want to work or
they're not maybe working in even the
fields they want to work they're maybe
instead of working as an engineer
they're working 20 hours a week at the
local bookstore at starbucks and these
people are are included
in u6 and the reason why i want to
really highlight that and mitch pointed
this out to me is that
this
is increasing much faster than this and
we'll think a little bit about why
that's happening and what conclusions we
can take
and what he did and these are
these are the numbers straight from the
bureau of labor statistics
and just so i know this screen right
here is really hard to see
but if you look at march 2008
the u3 number
was 5.2 percent and the u6 was 9.3 so
the difference between the two was about
what 4.1
but if you go to the most recent month
the standard unemployment number is 8.5
but the u6 the one that includes the the
discard workers the marginally attached
workers and the people who aren't
working full-time for economic reasons
the difference is now 7.1 percent so
that spread or i guess you could count
people who
would like to work but
they they've either stopped looking
because they've gotten dejected or
they've just you know bitten the bullet
and taken a job that they otherwise
wouldn't want to take or take taken few
hours and they otherwise wouldn't want
to take that's growing
that's growing and that really is
and and the reason why we really want to
focus on that is because it tells us
that even though the unemployment rate
the official unemployment rate and you
that is increasing very steeply and i'll
show a graph right here and this is
actually work that mish did where he
actually shows that the spread between
between u6
and u3 has been increasing and it's been
increasing at an accelerating rate since
last february and that's actually shown
right here in this graph where this is
and he got this from his friend chris
puplet financial sense so i want to give
him credit for it
but you see here u6 this is the broad
measure of unemployment that we talked
about right here that's increasing
at an even faster rate than the standard
unemployment measure and this green line
right here this is actually the
difference between the two and what
what's interesting about that is this is
kind of measuring
the percentage of the labor pool
that's getting dejected that's getting
depressed
and or that is so they're either getting
depressed or dejected and not looking
for work or they're just they're just
saying you know what i can't get a job
40 hours a week anymore as accountant i
will now go work part time at the local
department store or you know do whatever
it takes to put some uh food on the
table for for their families so it in
general shows a level of desperation
and if you look here
and this is really interesting this is
also from chris buffalo
is
if you look relative to the past you
know a lot of people the last major
recession that a lot of people talk
about is the early 80s the double dipper
session and even though our kind of the
headline unemployment rate and that let
me make sure i get the right color the
headline unemployment right here is the
blue line
that is still a good bit below we peaked
out there and kind of the i don't know
what the exact number is but looks about
a little in the mid 10 percent even
though we're a lot lower than that now
we're at eight point two percent right
now
if you look at
u
six which is the broadest that's spiked
up
that spiked up and unfortunately the
data for the u6 doesn't go back before
1994 they actually changed how a lot of
things were measured what we the
official headline rate instead of
calling it u3 it used to be called u5
but it was for the most part the same
measure but it's that's changed a little
bit but u6 did not exist before 1994 so
unfortunately we can't measure use u6
back then but a good i guess pseudo
indicator for u6 that we do have more
historical data on are the number
employed
15 the number of unemployed for more
than 15 weeks so these are people who
you know they've been looking for work
but 15 weeks or more they still haven't
found a job even though they've been
actively looking for work
and that if you look at least while we
have u6 being measured it has tracked
that broad measure quite well so if we
can kind of make the assumption that u6
is always is always on that line or
above it as it's graphed here which it
is so far
then u6 in the early 80s
u6 in the early 80s was probably
right around where that line is now
maybe it was a little higher maybe it
was up here but the the what this graph
really does convey is is that that
broadest measure of unemployment is
already as bad as it probably was in the
early 80s it's just we don't have that
data there and if anything those
part-time workers because they are
employed and so in the official
unemployment measure they're actually
making the number look a little bit
better so
they actually
you know here you had fewer people you
either employed or you were unemployed
if you're unemployed you made the number
look a little bit bigger here you have a
lot more people who who they're kind of
in between but they get they get counted
in the employed number so they're making
our that they're making the actual
reported you know official unemployment
rate a little bit lower than um is is
actually the economic reality i think
that's a really important thing to
realize that you have this kind of
accelerating rate of desperation out
there in the economy and if anything
it's telling us that things are getting
worse
and it's telling us that things are
probably as bad as they've been and some
of the worst recessions in history and
they're only getting worse and you know
going back to what we where we started
this video in terms of capacity
utilization and what that might do to
prices this tells us that
labor utilization
is low and going down
and what that tells us is the price of
labor is going down and i've
you've probably read multiple news
reports already about this is the first
time furloughs are being big are big
people actually taking wage uh they're
actually taking wage cuts so we're you
you're already seeing of the fl
deflation in wages and when so much of
our economy and even the baskets of
basket of goods in the cpi and i'll do
another video on that is service based
if you're seeing deflation in wages
that's another data point that tells you
at least in the medium term we're
probably going to see further deflation
uh in in prices as a whole
see in the next video